لغه كثير سرى حول توفر الارز في الاسواق
وخاصه مع اختفاء بعض اصنافه المعبئه من
قبل مضارب القطاع الخاص هذا الامر نفسه
الحكومه المصريه اكثر من مره خاصه مع
زياده المساحات المزروعه بالارز في محافظه
الدلتا المحافظه اجمالي مساحه الروسي
المنزارعه فيها تقريبا حوالي 800,000 فدان
النسبه دي زادت عن السنه اللي فاتت
بالنسبه تقدر بحوالي من 15 ل 20% تقريبا
عن كل فدان لمخازن وزاره التموين في بدايه
الموسم ولا حقت من يتقاعس او يقوم بتخزين
الارز التوريد كان ضعيف شويه في اول
الموسم ما كانش الناس تعرف كثير انت شايف
النهارده في اقبال على التوريد من قبل
المزارعين اما هنا في محافظه القاهره لم
نعود نجد بعض الاسماء التجاريه والعلامات
التي اعتنى عليها عند شراء الارز المعبا
لذلك يقوم ببعض اصحاب محلات البقاله
والسوبر ما ببيع الرز السايب كما يطلق
عليه هنا في مصر في اكياس يعبئونها
بانفسهم وهذا يصعر باكثر قليلا من السعر
الذي نصت عليه الحكومه المصريه بعض اصحاب
المتاجر رفضوا التصوير ولكن من وافق منهم
قال لنا ان الازمه عابره وتحدث كل موسم
حصاد هي الفتره دي اصلا الاسبوعين الجايين
دول اللي هم الموسم بقى بتاع الارز هيبقى
الموضوع بزياده وكل حاجه موجوده كثير يعني
اما في الاسواق فين في المستهلكونه وجود
ازمه ولكن يشكون ارتفاع السعر لا جامعات
استهلاكيه بنجيب منها
غيري حوالي 7 جنيه 8 جنيه بس موجود
انا مش لاقياه هو مش اسماء بس هو الناس
مخبينه شركات شايلاه عشان حصل له تسعيره
وقالوا انه ب 15 جنيه فاللي عايز يبيع
باكتر من 15لوله
[موسيقى]
الاستراتيجي من الارز يكفي الاستهلاك
المحلي لمده عام ونفت مدعته صفحات التواصل
الاجتماعي بوجود ازمه في كميات الارز
المعروضه تامر نصره العربيه القاهره